hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science and today I've got another tip
on compositing specifically compositing
textures over layers and let me show you
what I'm not here on one layer while on
one layer I've got my mtv logo on the
next layer I've got this animated
texture I created just a black and white
texture I've also got this colored like
watercolor paint texture and I've also
got this gray texture so all three
textures moving look like this they're
all they're all using transfer modes and
layer together to create this one
texture so what I see a lot of people
doing is is this they would take this
single logo layer they would duplicate
the logo and they would drag it above a
texture they turn that texture on and
they'd say alpha or luma matte this logo
then they would duplicate this layer
again bring it above the next texture do
the same thing alpha matte and then they
would duplicate the layer one more time
bring it to the very top of layer one
more alpha matte and then you end up
with this cool MTV logo and that works
great the only issue I have with it is
that now I've got eight layers here
including my background so if you've got
multiple other texture layers going on
multiple other layers in your comp
suddenly I've just added three
additional layers I don't need it's
getting a little bit messy so let me
show you a way that you can clean this
up and I'll undo all of this
and I'll turn these texture layers back
on and I'm going to go to effect channel
set Matt and this is a really cool
plugin comes with After Effects right
here where it says take Matt from layer
I'm going to change this from itself to
the MBLAQ layer which is the logo layer
tell it to recognize the Alpha Channel
and there we go
I'll copy this effect to this layer and
again to this top layer and as you can
see I've got five layers Maya comp is
way more clean and easy to work with and
I've still got the same layering effect
going on without using the alpha matte
or the luma matte it's a really simple
technique but yet it's very powerful so
that's it for today until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science